[Musique]
c'est un débat qui occulte pas mal
l'actualité ces derniers temps entre les
prix de l'énergie la coop 26 la campagne
présidentielle qui a démarré qu'elle
sera l'énergie du futur compatible avec
la sauvegarde de l'environnement et la
baisse des émissions de co2 pour
emmanuel macron il semble que ce soit le
nucléaire alors qu'en 2018 il annonçait
la fermeture de 14 réacteurs d'ici 2035
le triplement de l'éolien et la
multiplication par cinq du
photovoltaïque
il annonce le mois dernier dans le plan
d'investissement france 2030 le
développement de réacteurs nucléaires de
petite taille innovant pour un milliard
d'euros et on attend une annonce d'ici
cette fin d'année de la construction de
nouveaux apn ou réacteur pressurisé
européen si vous préférez le nucléaire
est considéré par certains comme une
énergie d'avenir par d'autres comme une
énergie de transition vers des énergies
plus renouvelable d'autres encore
voudrait en sortir le plus tôt possible
dès 2030 en france le nucléaire c'est
près de 70 % du mix électrique une
énergie prise en étau entre les risques
d'accident qui terrifie comme ça a été
vu avec tchernobyl ou fukushima et le
peu de co2 calais mais tout en
fournissant beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup
plus que certaines énergies
renouvelables comme l'éolien par exemple
qui recueille de moins en moins
d'adeptes de par ses dommages sur les
paysages sont faibles rendement donc le
besoin de terres rares pour sa
construction son incompatibilité
présumés avec le secteur de la pêche
pour l'éolien marin mais c'était pas la
seule énergie renouvelable solaire
hydraulique biomasse elles sont
nombreuses et semble être l'avenir
puisque aujourd'hui 80% des
investissements mondiaux sur le secteur
de l'énergie se ferait sur le
renouvelable